I do not pretend to be a medical professional.
I do not pretend to be a neurologist or a
mental health specialist, but fortunately,
none of those things are requirements to notice
that there is something very wrong with the
president of the United States.
And there's a new report that says Donald
Trump is regularly stumbling, slurring, and
confused at the white house.
Now I'll be totally upfront.
This could be drug abuse as we've covered.
This could be early stage dementia.
This could be some other form of cognitive
decline.
This could be the side effect of some medication.
We've not been told Donald Trump is on.
He's not been particularly forthcoming about
his health circumstances.
This could be any number of things, but it's
something that is what is very clear and it
keeps coming up.
Every time we hear from another white house
insider, there is a new book called a warning.
It's from the same anonymous staff member
who wrote that New York times op ed last year.
We have some viewers who are speculating about
who it might be, might be.
We'll talk about that in the voicemail segment
today.
They claim to be part of the resistance inside
the Trump administration and as usual, if
merely 5% of what's alleged in the book is
true.
It's caused for immediate alarm concern and
action.
Here is a quote from book per the Washington
post.
I am not qualified to diagnose the president's
mental acuity.
All I can tell you is that normal people who
spent any time with Donald Trump are uncomfortable
by what they witness.
He stumbles.
Slurs gets confused, is easily irritated and
has trouble synthesizing information.
Not occasionally but with regularity.
Those who would claim otherwise are lying
to themselves or to the country.
Now there's a bunch of other stuff in the
book about Trump making fun of women's physical
appearance, making fun of people's weight.
Trump is, you know, likely technically obese
by the way.
He still makes fun of other people's weight,
the regular stunned nature of the people around
him, but that stuff isn't even really news
or it pails in importance really compared
to this.
This is yet another data point.
It's another set of allegations pointing to
what is in plain sight.
Yet somehow it's considered to be in poor
taste to talk about this inappropriate to
talk about this.
This is the presidency.
This should go beyond party, unable to put
together coherent sentences, being very up
in one speech with dilated pupils and hours
later being down like he's coming down from
uppers and slurring and it's almost like he
can't get his tongue out of the way to speak.
Wanting to get to the oranges of an investigation,
repeating that twice, but looking confused
as if he recognizes that what's coming out
of his own mouth doesn't make sense, but seemingly
unable to make any sense.
Walking out of air force one, basing his limousine,
but starting to wander away until a staffer
can take them by the arm and bring them back
to the car.
Something similar happened when he was greeting
the Argentinean president at the G seven,
I believe it was in Argentina and on and on
and on.
So I implore you, put politics aside for a
moment.
This is an unfit person to be president merely
on the basis of his cognitive state alone.
Now, let me propose something that is now
floating around.
Um, there was a point of view that this is
all staged and concocted.
The idea is create a pretext for a Reagan
defense for Donald Trump if and when criminal
charges are brought against him, for who knows
which lists of the litany of criminal acts
that he likely has committed as president.
You know the thing about that that makes me
doubt it and I'm curious to see what you think
is that um, I don't believe Trump thinks that
that's going to happen and I don't know that
Trump is really putting people around him
in decision making situations who believe
that that is going to happen.
I just don't think Trump has any idea what
he's doing, period.
The motive is certainly there.
Uh, you might at some point face criminal
problems because of your presidency.
Let's start to create a pretext that you're
not cognitively with it.
I just don't think they believe Trump has
ever really going to face consequences for
what he's done.
And that's what makes me think the idea that
this is staged is unlikely to be the right
one.
I believe what we are seeing is just reality.
Donald Trump is barely being held together
by a thread and uh, we've actually got a specific
example from this weekend that I want to talk
about next.